for that let's let's get started
right okay
let's start let's start okay so uh
yeah so i i'm gonna finish um
basically the applications of the qsa
stuff for policy grading methods
and like i said present a bit of a
history and then after this
a lot of these ideas will be applied and
i mean this
uh under so andre benson who's the last
speaker today
uh was a student of nahum shimken in the
technion
so he's a he's a great rlr
and uh and also an optimizer uh and he's
going to talk about theory and
applications
and unrelated themes
so so i'm going to
you can't yeah by the way i suffered for
all of you
i suffered like you cannot believe
for all of you i suffered i
i left this week it was ruined because
of this lecture
and it's because of the history is so
wild
in the control area and
and i didn't believe the history and so
i was trying to validate it
and you'll see here it is and so this is
your question java
so i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna answer
a few things about the history of
policy gradients from my point of view
and i think
we'll see what peter says so here it is
the birth of policy grading methods in
control
a picture from a patent application in
france in 1922.
it's a railway engineer okay so
i'm not going to read this to you but
if you look at extreme seeking control
you know that funky diagram i showed you
of taking loss functions and
putting them through a filter and blah
blah blah blah
then every paper starts off the paper
with the same
sentence uh the origins of extremists he
can control were
found in the 1922 paper of leblanc
and i i spent the whole weekend trying
to see if this is true and
i contacted a friend in france to help
me dig up the paper or patent
application
and everyone just repeated the same
plagiarized everybody else
and so i wrote to ivan muriel's i found
this awesome paper that gave a history
and he had actually a longer essay which
is what's there
and he wrote to me on sunday evening and
he gave me more details
to prove to me he really read the paper
and it really was
doing exploration to optimize and try to
get the
the train to extract maximum power while
shooting through uh the streets of paris
so 1922 uh
i guess i guess i guess it's true um
and by the way somebody was saying that
this is making them carsick i'm sorry
i i tried to find a solution and i
couldn't find one
so maybe i should say switching slides
you close your eyes switching slides
um so i'm going to give you a lot a
bunch of history today
uh and again thank you to florence
forbes at india in grenoble and
ivan reels and uh in melbourne
for helping you find papers and and
doing the history
moving slides so i'm not go i just i'm
just showing some pictures
just to just just indicate the obsession
with od you know sort of gradient
descent ideas and adaptive control
and it really is worth looking at these
old papers and i did
in terms of torturing myself i just went
back to get a better feel of the point
of view back in the 80s um
and you know you just see let's do it
you know
you just see the derivative of some
parameter
as grady as something else based on
observables
everywhere in adaptive control you know
it's just uh
everywhere and you get these block
diagrams that's model reference adaptive
control
um what's funny is that carl astronaut
never embraced extreme seeking control
and i don't know why
he mentions that but he sort of just
moves on
um and uh what's really funny is that in
another survey we talked about adaptive
control
up to 1960 okay so he had a survey at
adaptive control in 1960 it was written
in 1996
and he he brags about neural networks
being promoted
um in the adaptive control literature
way back
uh way back when uh in the 1960s which i
think is pretty pretty
funny especially since in 1996 neural
networks were out of style
um they only came back to the stall a
little bit later is that true
i think neural networks had hadn't come
back yet no i think 1919
oh it was like really big hype i got
that
i remember it was really high that time
there's a huge hype in the field
that's why so he was trying to reclaim
territorial battle here
um but uh and then there's all this
stuff on the up enough techniques
and it's really worth uh you know
danny lieberts in illinois lecture notes
and adaptive control
focusing on layup enough techniques and
and peter kakodovitch who was at
illinois
this awesome educator his book
reference there is a great history and
techniques and stuff
so i'm just saying and a lot of it is
about you know model free
methods for tuning parameters based on
grading descent and other things like
that
so it's worth knowing about um
then there's policy gradient methods in
rl
and i just i always need an image for
new sections and does anybody know what
this is from
nope i don't i hope nice it's
it's it's the original contents it's a
close
it's been a buy i know
so i guess it's 2000 right that's that's
actually when nips was called nips
um and uh so do you all agree with this
language that
that actor only you're sort of doing
grading dissent or something
that's it and critic only is like you
learning
you know and then they're claiming that
actor critic is combining the two
because it's hard to get a consensus on
definition so
that's that's the reason i highlighted
these colors and all of that
okay now i remember reading this paper i
was really happy that they were
saying these things because
you know i don't know if if that's what
sutton has done this book i
i'm not sure um but i want to give you a
history from my point of view
of of their paper and then you know this
and this
actor critic method and so the origin in
my mind is
and when i teach optimal stochastic
control this is what i tell the students
that it started in 1968 uh with
um
a paper well i'll give you the reference
in a moment
where they uh they look at a
parameterized family
of markov chains parameters by parameter
theta
and he doesn't have a c sub theta but
let's let's do that here
let's suppose that we have a markov
chain x k there's a well-defined steady
state
so i'd like to minimize l theta
so for us
so this could be a pro this is going to
be a parameterized family of policies
and we'd like to
minimize the average cost of all
possible policies
um so um and so
so yeah so kind of sickles site williams
uh
reinforce is the first sort of
actor-only category
which would be like this and i and you
know you know everyone talks about
benrek's
paper um from 2018
and using that kefir wall forwards
okay so um
how can i drive his name it'll come
it'll come it'll come
so poisson's equation so remember
i told you all this is an incurable
disease
um i caught this in 1990 and that will
take me to my grave
everywhere i go it's there so
i've got a loss function which is
average cost
and and there's my cost function there
and what you can do is you can solve
poisson's
poisson's equation and then take the
derivative of both sides
um and when you take the gradient of
both sides
when i write grading i mean the grading
respect of theta
um you're going to get an expression for
it
in terms of expectations like this and
that is due to schweitzer
and it was actually this paper from uh
from
1968 it's actually his phd thesis
so it's a summary of his phd thesis from
mit which is a little bit earlier
and so he might not have written it this
way but this is what he did
you know so he took gradients to both
sides and then
if you take expectations after taking
the gradient you get two common terms
and you cancel them out because you
don't get steady state expectations
all right and i could do the details
slide change you know
if you take gradients of both sides
then you you get a a gradient of c
no problem there um
and then the tricky part nothing tricky
here yet
then this this is the product rule
you know right there i've got a product
of two things that depend on theta
that depends on theta that depends on
theta so i've got to use the product
rule
so i've got a gradient of p with respect
to theta there
and a gradient of h with respect to
theta there that's where it's at the
spiratual
and this is clear all right and then the
trick is then
to go through and fool around and
this is just a definition right
is it a definition
you know it's good the green the green
the log is just the gradient of p
divided by p so i've just multiplied and
divided by p
yeah so that looks familiar right so so
the ingenuity that came about from
ectocritic methods it's
unbelievable i mean you know i please
know that i'm not
dismissing anything but the origin of
perturbation theory markov chains is in
this paper by schweitzer
um and that's that whole thing about
score functions
you know is um is
is is found in his paper um and then
insane ingenuity came later um
yeah all right okay
um so
in terms of uh active credit methods
so this is a good view for i mean java
almost you did this already
so i'll go through it quickly i mean you
did this on monday
i just said it's different language now
um
but so you follow these design
principles i would like to
do grading descent and so
i don't have it so i do stochastic
approximation
you know because i have a formula for
the gradient it's um
this is completely unbiased move the
slide close your eyes
um and then you know
and then this beautiful fact is that you
can go through and and
uh and replace
this awful looking mass by
the q function times this square
function
you know and it's just a little bit of
algebra it's nothing is this from the
definition of c
theta you know it's because what is c
theta i mean c
theta of x is a summation over u
of c of x u times you know
in my notation the probability of
choosing u
given x you know so that's that's how
you
how you get that the same with p theta
and p theta is similar
right so you know this it just is
insanely beautiful
um and then so then you get a new essay
algorithm
with a slide um
well now i can put in my q function
times the square function
and go but of course just like q and
on where is q you know who is q
you know i should not make that joke i
know but
so then this insanely beautiful result
um just absolutely
insanely beautiful result from the
contents of cyclists paper
that um that we only need this
result to be true
you know we i mean let's see do i have
it here no
this is you know uh td1
as i described it saves the day
you know you choose compat what's called
what they call compatible features
for your q function approximation and t1
because it's
minimizing that uh that fell in air in
the right norm
you get this identity it's just
absolutely beautiful so it's one of the
most beautiful
results in mathematical rl for me
again i it's a lot i don't know so uh
chaba you know i mean i know there's a
lot i don't know okay
so there's history all right
okay questions ridicule
no okay so let's talk about how you'd
apply these ideas
um to a policy grading rl
um so uh this was done for you at java
do you recognize that number
i recognize what oh yeah that number
yeah do you recognize it mon temple
well yes the tallest mountain in alberta
so yeah um
so um so the mountain car we've already
seen the mountain car problem
you know we we have rich sudden who
wants to drive to the top is
the highest peak in alberta i don't know
if that's possible
[Laughter]
but he doesn't have a lot of power so he
stalls
and what he does is he puts in reverse
goes full speed shoots back
and then goes full speed forward and
back and forward
and eventually makes it to the top you
know and and
you don't want to keep going over it's
forever because you'll shoot over this
hill
and end up in british columbia yeah
all right all right so here's a
particular policy which i'll explain in
a moment
but um so what i'm showing here sideways
is the example the famous example of
sutton
as it's normally shown where this is
nice curve here
and the the range of um
of latitude is is limited um
and what i've got is two different
policies which i'll explain in a moment
and three different initial conditions
so here
i'm starting at the top of the hill and
i actually if i
start off at full speed you know full
throttle i end up at the top
so that's why i just shoot to the top
done i'm starting here with maximum
speed
wham i get there done in this one i'm
starting the valley
so i'm starting here and so i i go
forward
and then stall go backwards go forward
and then i reach the top
you know and here's a bit better
actually here i'm actually starting
not better it seems better i'm starting
very close to the goal
but i'm stopped so i have to roll back
down
and i end up look at look how bad the
policy is
it goes all the way back to the peak
here
and it's stuck for like 50 seconds i
mean like 20 seconds
it's their time steps before it's
because it
it's because there's um it's because of
the model
it takes a while for speed to go from
negative to positive
so this is another one with a different
parameter where it takes a lot more
oscillations from the valley to get to
the top
but it doesn't spend so much time stuck
on the on the wrong peak
so i haven't defined the policies that i
will in a second
all right but this is a parameterized
family of policies which i'll explain
and we'd like to find the best policy
within that class
is the setup clear
okay so i should explain what this means
um
okay so the goal is the minimum time to
travel to destination j
i'm just the destination and that's my
value function j of x
you know which is i should write it down
so the cost function's just one and uh
you know oh now let's make it infinity
why not
you know it's equal equal to one until i
reach the destination and then zero
all right um and then um
what i'm going to do is i'm going to i'm
going to say protect myself a little bit
so i'm going to look at the average cost
um so basically where i choose initial
conditions
you know so i'm basically going to
randomly select
i'm not allowed to use the word random
i'm going to select a whole bunch of
initial conditions
maybe quasi randomly and in order to
avoid infinite numbers i'm going to
minimize with a
some value j max because i otherwise i
don't know
i i might have a policy for which this
is infinity and it'll mess up my
algorithm
so that's the loss function i'd like to
minimize and let's do it by gradient
descent
okay um so this is like an average cost
oh yeah here i actually say that it
could be an average cost by the way
and the algorithm would be fine that i'm
proposing whether it's
is a stochastic model a deterministic
model the algorithm is the same
it doesn't make any difference the
theory would change a bit
and then i've got this uh this procedure
right i
i i would like to degraded descent
that's my goal
right and i can't do that exactly
in a model-free manner so i have an
approximation
you know so these are not exactly equal
so this is an example where
f bar is not exactly equal to f
i mean i mean to the thing i want and
then there's a translation
so how would you do it this is a short
lecture
i just want us to think about it so
the sort of model you would look at you
know you would identify
if you actually played around with the
simulator long enough or if you looked
at twitch southern's book
is that if you take the state to be
position and velocity and discrete time
um then the new position
is the old position the new position
is the old position plus this discrete
time velocity okay
and there's plus a disturbance you know
disturbance is because you're going
uphill
or downhill or whatever so there's a
state dependent disturbance here
i just don't want to have to specify it
you know um
and then there's the stickiness i
mentioned here that there's some value
gamma
which is like 10 to the minus 3 in the
sudden smoke i don't remember
times my input u and the input u takes
on value
0 1. okay
oh zero one minus one and one shut the
mistake in my slides
it's minus one or one so i'm either
trying to go have the throttle and fall
forward or fall backwards
um but you see the problem the model
has a sticky v and so that's why you get
stuck in one boundary for a long time
so the disturbance captures everything
shallow captures
the landscape it captures effect there's
a projection going on everything
okay um and again
typo
um so here's the policy i'm talking
about i have a parameterized
family of policies for which um
i have a parameter theta and what i do
is i put
i construct a prediction
let me uh write this down
i didn't have to do this i was just
messing around i construct a prediction
of my next state value why not you know
we have a prediction let's use it we
didn't have to
um and if it's less than a period of
theta it means i'm
far from my goal and what the hell i'm
going to hit the gas
and head towards my goal any way i can
um
this is not informed by what the apple
policy looks like it's not like this at
all
the outbound policy has different
structure um
while if i'm not panicking i go with the
flow
whatever direction i'm going i push to
go even faster in that direction
all right so this is just from some just
just
it's a it's something to play with okay
and um i was hoping to give a
two-dimensional example
but blame it on nips or nerves
okay so we want to find the best theta
so how would we use this qsa theory to
accomplish that goal
well you've got to use batch methods
it's the only way that i know of
okay so somebody else has a different
idea tell me but
to me the clearest way to apply this is
using batch techniques
um okay all right
so so that's that's what this is right
so this is actually
the performance of this policy the way
it's behaving
um for these two different guys so you
see here
i have one example where theta equals
minus 0.8 which is way down over here
and i have another one with theta equals
minus 0.2 which is over here
so this one is panicking all the time i
mean
every time it's over here it's giving up
and just hitting the gauss
well this one doesn't panic very much at
all it's only when it's
it's quite close to the uh to the uh to
the
left side closer to british columbia
okay um it turns out this is the optimal
done by brute force calculation um
for the setup that i looked at okay even
though it's
in this example it's worse you know um
there's one for these three initial
conditions this policy does this bit in
this policy for one initial condition
okay so let's look at let's play around
with this
and let's think about what how would we
implement these two algorithms
and i i i can't yeah oh good good good
and so maybe i should stop somebody tell
me what they would do
what's ill
well whether you got to the top
or not yeah yeah yes we sort of went
down haven't we yeah um let's just make
sure it's in front of us
so this is l but we're not going to take
an infinite limit
so we need a noisy um
[Music]
uh surrogate for hell
oh god nikki got sick i'm sorry
so this hell to answer your question
but we need a surrogate you know we need
a we need
what we need is you know
something observable and with limited
data
and i guess it's right there but just
use it
so we can't use this l so
this is this is the original definition
by the way yeah i hate to say but you
have a typo here is
x not go to xn not xk
oh obviously oh schweitzer
thank you yeah
yeah so these are these are supposed to
be sampled initial conditions
um so we could we could
get rid of the n and define that to be l
uh but why not just take that so let's
let's that this is the thing
i should put an l bar there now this we
define the thing
and let's just call that you know l
it's sort of like l of theta noise
and you see i'm going to get into
trouble because i can't i can't exactly
apply this algorithm
so i chose this example in part so my
first initial condition to be pristine
it would just be exactly qsa as i
defined it
but um but i don't want to i want to be
able to look at the average
cost you know over a big range of
initial conditions
right so we need a slight extension
close your eyes everybody
um so the slide extension is this what
we do is we
for each n we perform an experiment
we uh for each n we
choose an initial condition you know
and we choose a a uh a parameter
so so uh basically an experimented time
in
so it's not really batch but it's not
it's not like this microscopic following
the process
i just take an initial condition
you know which i just saw i choose here
i choose a parameter fixed
fixed and i i i
i observe this value function from a run
you know with this parameter and with
this initial condition
you know and that's what i plug into
this uh to this guy
and um and and yes java
this is a great example you'll be in big
trouble if it's not
if it's if the model is stochastic
because if the model is stochastic these
are different l's
so it requires a deterministic reality
i mean so method one
i'm so glad you brought that up method
one requires
that the repeated experiments are the
same it requires deterministic
uh world
but not to not one aim
because because because of the fact that
i put in this oh yeah
um i mean here
i identify my l with this parameter and
this parameter
so these guys everything that cancel out
nicely the l's have to be the same
you know um yeah so
so anyway so in the experiments it was a
a deterministic world
but let's first look at the so this one
doesn't so this this this is perfectly
valid in the stochastic world
now there's a issue but this is the one
that i tried out
and it was magic like i said um it's
uh but as i said before typical
trajectories
don't seem to take they take a long time
to converge the exact value
but they get in you know basically where
it's minimized
very very quickly i mean just like that
and if you
instead of sine waves
if you put an iad uniform
it just doesn't it takes forever it's
almost worthless
so that's one way you can apply these
things is
is in this case it's sort of a batch i
mean in this case it's so natural to use
a batch method you
you do a run you do it on because it's
an ultimate goal
but in general i would try a batch
method as well maybe you know just look
at
or and find horizon problems it's
completely natural
okay so um
so that's that i don't know when we
started
uh but i wanted this to be a bit lighter
oh yeah yeah but comparison of the two
qsa algorithms so this is the one that's
not
lipschitz and this is the one that is i
found i had to double the gain
um which i don't really understand why
considering these two guys have almost
identical
ods i was surprised that the behavior
was as different
as it was um but i guess it has to do
with the fact that
my theory depends on the lipsticks
continuity
um but uh but here
it um it's just it gives it gives you
the same answer every time
um every you know i'm doing a thousand
independent runs from different
initial conditions for theta and uh
and this is way more reliable when you
can use it
okay so in conclusion
i presented a beautiful hopefully
marriage of probability theory control
and reinforcement learning
and it's funny for me to emphasize that
considering the entire
last two hours have been trying to
eliminate this
and replace it with sine waves um
but uh but anyway that's that's the
message i still think
that probably theory is insanely
valuable and
every step of analysis was inspired by
the probabilistic analysis for stogastic
approximation
um and every bit of the theory
that you could find in those lecture
notes either adapts or steals theory
outright
from stochastic approximation and it's
easy
because this is covariance matrix which
is zero that's what makes things so
simple
compared to the analysis and in the
stochastic case
it's you'll see it's way way easier
close your eyes
um you know
this is you know is it really so useful
in finance
i don't know
so the very first paper i've seen on
this was from a finance professor in
france
but the volatility uncertainty it
dominates everything i don't think my
little sign waves are going to help that
um high dimension i mean jesus you know
we've got
all these friends machine learning
they'll do batch coordinate
batch algorithms i i bet you know we you
know our friends will help us
um i definitely not promoting
a million dimensional vector of sine
waves which is what you'd need
no no no no um and i think it'd be fun
to combine all this stuff with
other modes of acceleration again again
the friends here meaning the ml
community
um so there's lots of collaboration
there that i think will be cool
um and um yeah
and then and then i'd love to apply this
to some cool
applications the best
most obvious application on earth is
wind farms
there's no way you have a model there's
no way you can take a gradient
you can just collect the energy that's
being delivered by this wind farm
and then adjust the pitch of the and the
orientation of the turbines and try to
make them oscillate and excite them it
would optimize
it would be it'd be a blast so i'm
begging you andre
nrel
um so yeah that's that's all
[Music]
so that's all for me
[Laughter]
i'm sorry you can't join me it's uh
oh yeah that's a pity i know
i'll wait till after under his lecture
yeah i'm going to say that save that for
after lecture
uh yeah people uploading on chat as well
yeah i wanted to uh
ask you like reinforcement learning is
is just a complicated optimization
meth optimization problem from from this
perspective right
um
um right there's only this last one
yeah yeah this is i'm not this is not
how i define rl it's just one approach
sure um yeah yeah sorry sir i i didn't
mean that
uh yeah i just make sure everybody knows
that there's one approach
yeah um maybe i'm just reflecting on
that
uh if you want to understand this
uh quasi uh
stochastic uh quasi-monte carlo approach
it would be more natural to you know
just start with
i guess the previous part of the lecture
was like that that
you just want to solve a pure
optimization problem what a
good online learning problem
and and try to
understand what the advantages uh
of the quasi-monte carlo approach could
be there
yeah it's really hard isn't it yeah
what's that if
if you can only make uh like in online
learning
uh you know like you have a sequence of
loss functions you're trying to
minimize regret let's say uh and losses
are convex maybe they live ones
something simple as zero one interval
uh but you can only make one measurement
yeah
uh then one approach is to randomize
but maybe randomization uh you made me
think that
uh it's not so essential so we we tend
to think that okay you should randomize
to gain
a little bit more information about you
know the function
randomization and yeah makes
a lot of things estimating quantities of
interest
uh much easier um
but is like have you said about whether
with this uh one point measurements
uh in the online setting uh the
quasi-random approach
would also be a viable approach
um well yeah i mean the thing is that i
can
i can give you results for this if you
allow me to project
you know the whole problem is stability
you know i
i don't think this is stable so you know
yeah so the theory for this the theory
for this is crisp
if you allow me to project onto a
complex sub right
um or or mess with it you know just sort
of
you know l starts out quite i mean
strongly convex a and then make it look
more linear for large
theta and then everything's okay um
so you need to know have a prior and
where theta is
you know and then you then you can run
this thing for sure
and the theory will will go through you
know
and and then you'll get the one you'll
you'll get this faster rate of
convergence
if you design the algorithm properly
yeah and now i suddenly don't like one
of ran anymore
you know
um
okay yeah but it's i mean
but i did
[Laughter]
when i project ran this experiment i did
project and you can see here i mean
look how crazy keva wolf i mean uh nike
forwards
the stochastic dynamics are compared to
the
i mean look at this it's every
trajectory wants to get a different
value um but maybe it's a stepsister
tuning question there
yeah that's true that's true i did but i
did mess around i really tried okay
i really was being fair here i used
constant step size i use
one over square root of n i use i mean
one of the and this i mean one of
endlessly halves things like that
um i did not i promise you i didn't take
i did not just show you the worst
example i really didn't
the worst examples were point masses at
the boundaries of where i projected
so someone asking i'm not sure if i
understood the one a argument was for
the case of stochastic and yet you don't
think it is stable oh no it's not stable
so this algorithm here unless you
project theta it's not stable
[Music]
and i mean here the domain of theta is
naturally bounded so it doesn't
it doesn't really apply so um
so but um
i guess what whoever has destruction is
uh meaning
that uh this is key fair wolf of it's uh
well it's not really i don't know
in the lecture notes i accidentally
write kw here this is a sloppy error
because this is kiefer wolfowitz with
ied noise
um so this i'm calling it i didn't have
a name for it so it's just
the second algorithm one a is this is
or yeah uh is it infinite
a single point spsa um
like one point measurement spss
simultaneous perturbation stochastic
approximation
2000 or something yeah yeah he's the
first
he's the first drastic reference in the
control side that made reference to
kevin wolf with
that i could find i should have
referenced him actually
um yeah but um
but you'll hold a second i i kind of
misspoke everybody
we do have conversions without for these
uh if you're controlling
with projection yeah there's no way i
can improve
this projection yes but here like
what what we see on these trajectories
is nothing like convergence
well here you're similar i can tell you
what the problem is
so um where's so
so notice that this
blue curve here sorry it's hard to read
um this blue curve here
is my objective function you know that's
that's j of theta okay
um yeah or l of theta whatever by my
real
l of theta um and you notice it's quite
steep and then quite shallow
okay and in order to get
good behavior because of that steepness
i need a small gain
and then and and so if i
and what happens is if i don't take my
this to be small enough i get insane
shattering
it just goes way way way way way where
where
you get look at this this this behavior
here persists
for the entire run and it's because of
the
steepness and then flat you know so it's
it's numerically
it badly behaves because of that um
and so this thing ends up you know
avoiding the steep regions
and so it doesn't get blasted out every
time you're here you just get this
chattering that's crazy
that's how you get these big outliers um
[Music]
yeah and even even i guess that's the
just it bounces around
um but so i had to make in order to not
have a thing something was just
chattering for the whole run
i reduced again and both so they both
have the same uh step size
so that i got something at least
reasonable on the right side
um it'll converge you let it run long
enough it'll converge
uh but this is but this is you know
i can prove one over n and this is one
over well not one around
log log n
over n yeah um if you it best
yeah um actually i didn't use it one way
in step size
i used one of our end of the nine tenths
or something
i'll put that in
okay we do have another question and
just a quick clarification question
by projecting projection to human
projection onto a smaller space
what would you mean oh i just mean that
uh
that i said i then after both of these
i i i
um how do i say this
just says
if you have an interval or something
yeah so here i have an interval so i can
just i could just do that
and i had to do it uh in this example
um it just it just didn't work um
you know um you know just
yeah oh i have to because of the thing
i'm sorry but i had to i mean
what am i trying to say um
honestly i got myself confused that's
something else no no here was
instability but i had to because of the
physics
okay i do have a very high level
question
i guess maybe it's it's just way too
high so i'm trying to think about
uh okay this talk is supposed to be you
know like
control perspective brought into rl
and we're talking about some aspects of
control theory that are impacting
ireland have been
impacting real uh like stochastic
approximations
obviously uh like some history of like
this extreme seeking
uh yeah but most of control theory is
not like this
no no no no so 90
of control theory is about
you know linear systems and transfer
functions
um and then and then just like in every
field they're cults you know so people
look at consensus
or mean field games you know which is
the great thing about academia i think
that this
people form a a little clan
and they feed off each other and come up
with ideas
um and i i
i chose these topics both because
they're exciting to me and because i
thought i thought they um
reflected things that were relevant um
like i mentioned controlled lyapunov
functions or as a whole another
cult or or tribe tribe is the word
within control for which are all sorts
of ideas that could be useful
so i mentioned that in the first lecture
but it's just too hard to get into it
and they would use these same techniques
they would use like gradient descent
techniques like we talked about um
yeah so i guess my very high level
question would be
uh can you think off the top of your
head about
other areas
ideas that are overlooked
by people working on our rail that we
should bring in
we should pay more
yeah um
[Music]
yeah we should need entropy yeah uh who
else
i've mentioned too you know ml is a
no-brainer
we have to seduce them into this and um
and also some numerical analyst types
[Music]
and yeah yeah and then can cause them to
call it crowd but no i can't
i mean it's true you're right it's too
hard i can't think of an answer right
now
it'll come to me i'll have to sleep on
it but it's a good question
and if you yeah i think
um it's an open-ended question rooney uh
is asking is it possible to use poncho
in principle in rl
like it is done in stochastic control
can we recover some
of leaning this way
well oh god thanks for that question so
oh man that's awesome
um so
oh wow so um
we need to do it so so uh
um it's like uh i haven't seen a paper
where it's done
you see oh yeah let me let me step back
for a second i'll answer the question
but so uh from from practitioner's point
of view
like 99 of what's done in practice like
in all sorts of things chemical
engineering process control
i don't know all sorts of people get
paid a lot of money they're not exciting
applications they use what's called mdc
you know receding horizon control they
solve a fine horizontal control problem
you know and they throw everything but
the first action
and they repeat the optimization problem
and um
um and the solution to that
to those uh fine horizon optimal control
problems
are based on the h jb equations if it's
continuous time
and um
and you know we can do what we've been
doing now and take time as a variable
and just use it use q learning or
whatever
but but yes i i would so prashant and
i've been talking about this for 10
years
and and uh he'll he'll kill me for
saying this but
of trying to sort of reinvent rl by
really looking more carefully
at the minimum principle you know which
is about just directly solving
the state and co-state equations and and
coming up with algorithms based on that
and i'm sorry prashant yeah but that's
something
so prashant you it's been 10 years
yeah this is a good time to do it so
renee if you want to collaborate on that
you know please i i i would love to uh
just sort of come with a whole new
framework based on all the beautiful
concepts of the minimum principle it's
an amazing
machine because you know it's a great
sudden picked out
the the similarity between the q
function the hamiltonian
and we expanded it on that 2009 paper
but but that's a com
that's not it that's not the minimum
principle
i could say more if you want me to um
yeah
yeah um okay
the q function is a compression of the
minimum principle
um you know the minimum principle is a
two-point boundary value
problem you know you you what i want to
minimize
you know integral theorem to t of c of x
d u t d
t you know and i end up with a
lagrangian in a way
you know x dot equals f of x
and then i've got this lagrangian um
god i'm going to get scared here so
there's uh
so um
yeah i'm getting myself scared so
there's the dynamics
um i've got uh
no oh hold on i've got the notation but
you end up you end up with a state you
have the state dynamics you have a code
state
um which i'm not gonna i guess i can't
write down right now
um because this is considered a
constraint
mm-hmm yeah
and so it turns out that there's
something oh that's right i'm sorry well
let's see
it's the i get i'm having i'm just a
little bit flustered because
pf plus l
damn damn damn me
everybody just wait a second okay please
so it's just p transpose
f um plus c
well of course f and c
are functions in x and u so it's really
all written out
no that's fine i think we got it
yeah i've got it i just i just realized
that some people don't know what i'm
talking about
what's a variable what's it what's not
okay
okay so so we know that x dot
is equal to the gradient of h
uh at xpu everybody can see that right
because it's linear in p
and we know that x dot equals f and then
is it the negative
and that's that's um partial p
gradient p and p dot equals minus
gradient x
so that's that's the minimum principle
and there's an amazing fact
that uh p turns out to be e
when you find it it's like a p star of t
it's equal to the gradient of the value
function
evaluated at x g star
also depends on t if it's find a horizon
all right
so um um so
um so in the continuous time it's not so
clear
but when you after this plug-in is when
you see the q function connection
you know this leads to a connection to
the q function
sure that's not what i'm talking about
now what rene is talking about i think
this whole beautiful theory should be a
beautiful oyster to crack
and create new url or elegance would be
really practical
um
[Music]
is there an um equivalent of these for
the stochastic case
yeah um i guess if you mean you can
probably
there is it's it is messy it's true um
you know people are still writing papers
on this on stochastic minimum principle
and stuff
yeah yeah it's not it's not as elegant
but but the thing is oh but i wish i had
time
if you if you look at me it's not there
so many problems
even if they're stochastic you can
pretend that deterministic can get a
really good solution
it really is true i if we had time i'd
explain why
that's true it's very often you can
bound the error
so what is that oh okay you know you
just run the algorithm attendance
deterministic
and this you can you can see what it
converts to
and it's really pretty close to what you
cared about and i can give you a formula
for the gap in um and say discounted
cost structural control
yeah um and if there's huge volatility
you're screwed
okay it's only you know but if but in
normal problems
yeah some regularity must must be there
because
i can easily come up with problems where
it's absolutely not true
you need and i have to go back but it's
amazing how
robust it is it's all about volatility
not about smoothness
yeah i i think it is it yeah it would be
interesting to see this
uh i've got i've got it written up i
think it might be this lecture notes um
um oh no it's in it's in that paper so
if you look in discord
somebody dug up that um that
by lecture two is based on an archive
paper
um there's a whole section devoted to
when can we ignore volatility okay
yeah and it's it's it's um
it's simple but it's just uh you know
it's the kind of justification that
control people have in mind all the time
when they they do design pretending that
the world is deterministic when they
know it's not
okay yeah i think our times
wait like what what was the so the next
talk is 4 30
no that's that's i mean it's okay i just
don't want to buy it into the time of
the next store but i think
we are fine uh because the next is going
to start at 4 30. that's fine
so we do have a bunch of questions in
the q a okay cool
cool um so ahmad's asking
in our lineup feedback system scenario
book
uh you sean mentioned fluid models and
cues
in chapter eight can you quickly explain
the connection between our hat and these
concepts
oh wait wait which one's the the
flowchart
of your new feedback systems in our
apple oh yeah
oh that's so funny so yeah um
so if if so
sean's tutorial
in 2010
would have been
you know can you say q theta of x u
equals i'll write it out longhand
what is it how uh how to choose
how to choose the features okay yeah
okay yeah because
because i'm sorry i'm slow i didn't
believe in neural networks
i had no idea you know all right
how about 2009. because by tis and ted i
think i knew
no no i didn't no no i'm not gonna
pretend i was i was ignorant in 2010
as well i had no idea what would happen
with no networks i just
i was in i was in a cave um
and but the thing is that there are so
many methods
for model reduction and why not put them
to use in an architecture for you
learning or tv learning
um so if you look at my book on networks
the final chapter is about that
um and so it's really about that it's
basically architectures
that's one way you can use model
knowledge in order to get an
architecture
is that you know the value functions
convex a piecewise convex
piecewise quadratic blah blah blah and
you you
dump that into your architecture and
for cueing networks in particular there
are mean field
models there are od models of qe
networks
where there's so much structure for the
value function it's insane
and so it's crazy not to use that
structure
you know the value function
[Music]
is smooth it's piecewise quadratic all
sorts of structure
um so that's what that that's what that
section the chapter of the book is about
and i i have a book chapter i wrote yeah
in fact
c book chapter 2010. the whole book
chapter on the topic
yeah okay so what's the title of the
tutorial
just shows it's feature selection
for neurodynamic programming that was
supposed to be a joke
i always liked that title even though it
didn't catch on
i thought it was cute
and also it was you know i just feel
like um
all of mine my first love in rl was the
stuff coming out of
mit you know jonathan cyclist and ben
van dore and condo
you know that was my starting point
[Music]
for many of us so
russian has another high-level question
ariel encompasses the trajectory
planning part of control
rather than just stabilization using
theory has useful ideas
to approach this problem
there seems to be a lot of interesting
exploration to solve this
why wait which thing so what's this i
guess
like the trajectory planning part of
like the high-level planning like
conceptualizing the whole thing together
like you have the task and like cutting
it
down and yeah that's what you think
about like in ride sharing sort of i
mean sort of macro
problems where there's so much
complexity and all that
and exploration is so huge you know
um absolutely that's a big part and you
see that's what i
have not talked about you know and it's
not because i don't think it's important
it's just too hard
to fit in um
but i guess yeah control people
uh when they approach a problem like
this what's the thinking what's the
butter toast they're thinking about
over the trajectory planning problem
it's yeah basically yeah i mean it's all
model based so they have forecasts of
traffic
they say the problem of driving across
the city they have
they assume forecasts of traffic with
some bounds on the
on the uncertainty in this forecasts um
you know and they and they they will
build up
a state model with those features
you know in their optimal control
problem um
[Music]
and and so there's no
the only time you'll see exploration is
when people do adaptive control
and then you get the same issues the
sense of excitation
being sufficient exploration um
and all that but
um yeah
yeah the adaptive control community
dropped the ball
on the trajectory planning problem
because that would have been where they
could have made the most impact
instead of that higher level thinking
i think they made they made a few
mistakes that's that's another one
but i think it wasn't as well understood
it was sort of glossed over
in education you know it's a it's a
usual gap of the
people doing the theory and the people
put it to practice there's a wall
in most communities between the two
and so
yeah i would explain it okay
okay uh so omid uh kosravani
uh asking a question uh he says
i like your paper and minimum principle
interpretation of q learning
other works that find the relationship
between
heb equation with actor critic
oh cool not that i know of no wouldn't
that be fun
i don't know i mean duality is right
there so it must be
it must be sitting there maybe somebody
else in the audience knows
we'll see uh
yeah like maybe maybe someone's going to
write something
um i don't uh know much about this
so there's a comment here
addressed to me i don't know related to
my
high level question and something in
control that might be overlooked in our
app personally i think robust control
might be one of such
things i see there were beautiful
theories about designing robust
controllers that can tolerate
disturbance adversarial noises
which may be useful for developing
robust safe algorithms nowadays in some
it seems that the current creation
between rl and contrary is more on
adaptive control
and optimal control two important topics
in control but less and robust control
and at the corner story
although we should mention group has
been really active
like others to on bringing ideas from
robust control to rl
it's not completely overlooked but
also in rl uh just off the top of my
head
robust mdps is a separate thing
yeah so do you do you agree with this
sean that
uh well in terms of people that should
be brought in
they're already in the people doing game
theory
are already writing to rl like timothy
shaw
is one um
yeah the the non-linear part of robust
control
is all sort of game theory where you
have disturbances that are adversaries
and you're trying to control for the
worst uh adversary
um and tamara bashar has a million books
on this is a big
a big discipline and they so there could
be ideas there
in the the game theory and robust
control literature would be useful
but for me the most elegant parts of
robust control were all for linear
systems just
quite amazing theory there
[Music]
so omid was just noting about the
previous command that okay there is a
speedy audi correspondence going on so
that's why he thinks i think that
heb and q learning quality
will happen sure in a way yeah
yeah all right i think that we should
let people
uh take a break uh it's a wonder that so
many stayed
um so thanks everyone uh things shown
uh big big thanks uh thank you
what about a pleasure man yeah it was
wonderful
uh i enjoyed it very much
very much uh and looking forward to
the next talk by andre
thanks okay thank you
we should drink the thing uh once again
that's right
i still have to wait today